if the 4 pm deadline passes and the
government decides it's not going to
comply in full with the the ruling by
baroness hellert then in theory
um they could be committing a criminal
offense under the inquiries act
um and criminal proceedings could be
taken
um another option is that the baroness
helleck could refer the matter to the
high courts and the high court would
then make an order deciding what to do
next and then a third option is that the
government could tell baroness Hallett
that they're going to judicially review
her and they have until next week early
next week to do that because they're
only it's only 14 days from the decision
that was taken and if they if they
decide to judicially review her it's
unlikely that any enforcement action
will be taken in the meantime but that
would be heard I suspect pretty quickly
by the high courts
um Boris Johnson has said the request
for his WhatsApp messages and the diary
entries could reach government rules on
disclosure because of National Security
issues
I don't think National Security is the
issue here because I think from my
understanding of the ruling um baroness
Heller accepts that certain elements
would be would not be provided to you on
a national security basis I think it's
the it's the it's the other things it's
then it's the material which isn't
connected directly to the covid response
but baroness Hallett says I want all of
I want everything related to everything
that was happening in that period and
because I want to see what pressures the
Prime Minister was under and his
officials and what other issues they
were dealing with to get the full
context of what was happening happening
during this extraordinary crisis so it's
it's a very wide request and quite an
unusual one
um but
um one that baroness Taylor says well I
I know I'm the decider of relevance and
I because of the extremely unusually
wide
um in terms of reference that I have I
really do need to see everything and to
get the full picture
and as I was saying there is um
precedent previously wasn't a Judicial
inquiry it was a public inquiry uh the
chilcott inquiry but the committee
um was told that it would be able to
request any British document and call on
any British citizen to give evidence but
we're just debating that with our
previous contributor saying that that
was back in 2009 that was before
WhatsApp messages people are much more
um easy to speak to each other much more
um open one might say with each other on
something like WhatsApp just something
like that need to be taken into account
well there's no um there's nothing
unusual in the in the court and inquiry
system of seeing what set message is um
they've been and text messages generally
have been they're disclosable they're
relevant if they're relevant documents
they are and they need to be disclosed
to courts and they are on as a matter of
course I mean in lots of cases that I'm
involved in with the government you've
seen messages because that's as you say
a lot of the time that's how public
officials communicate to each other the
the sort of wider question is in the
context of a of an all-encompassing
emergency response which the pandemic
was it was a very it wasn't a usual sort
of public issue where there would be
Parcels of time and meetings devoted to
it it was you'll remember it was it
dominated the news it dominated
everything for two years um you could
barely um get to do anything else
without it involving covert and I think
when you've got a series of WhatsApp
messages between government officials
during that period
um a lot of it will be relevant because
attacks but also I think the other thing
that baroness Helen is worried about is
that she's not if the government decides
what's unambiguously irrelevant which is
the words that it's using
um it's going she doesn't trust that
that will Encompass everything she needs
so in the example what they did to prove
to her to try and prove to her that they
were doing a good job they they provided
us a short section of messages which was
unredacted to say look we've given you
everything in the previous
um bundle of documents we've given you
everything that we should have and she
said well actually there were messages
in that you redacted that related to the
police response to the Sarah everard
vigil which was all about the covert
rules so um that's not a good start and
not promising start she said in the
ruling and I think that that's the other
main reason that she's not willing to
allow the government itself to be the
decider of its own of relevance she says
I'm the decider of relevance I'm the
inquiry chair I have a much better
understanding of what I need to be
worrying about than you do so I think
that's where that's where she's coming
from and that would be the issue or the
justification that would be
um presented to a court if it ever goes
to courts
that's your best based on what's going
to happen Adam Before I Let You Go
um I have absolutely no idea I mean it's
it's not it's not a situation I've seen
before it's not the width of the request
is I think
um unprecedented or at least close to
unprecedented in a public inquiry but I
can entirely see the logic
um because the covert uh pandemic itself
was unprecedented so we are we are in
Legally speaking untested Waters which
is why the government um the government
will be really worried about setting a
precedent of being having to give
everything
um even documents which don't relate to
a particular crisis to inquiries and so
they may be willing to take the take the
public risk of challenging it and
um and we'll see what happens